paranormal activity it's a staple of
Halloween and now it's like the
Paranormal Activity trilogy so let's
review the third one paranormal activity
3 right so if you remember I really
loved the first Paranormal Activity
movie I really liked the second
Paranormal Activity movie I had a couple
issues with it but I still loved it the
third one's a bit of a mixed bag for me
first of all this one's a prequel takes
place in 1988 it shows the two girls
that were in the first and the second
movie shows how this all happened there
were things I liked this movie is it a
creepy movie yeah it still carries the
torture of being a creepy ass movie
however if you remember I praised the
first one for not having jump scares you
know it relied on your psychology to
freak you out and that feeling of not
being safe no jump scares I really like
that this one has a few in fact I'd go
so far as to say that it was relying on
jump scares at a point and I hated that
I felt like paranormal activity was like
signing everything away to the enemy
yeah you know stuff like haha gotchu
jabronis and I was like I come on dear
just you know had the demon terrorize
the kids but you don't have a sweet
tooth mask at your house but you sir are
letting the best in life pass you by and
at first a demon felt a little playful I
was like he's not menacing he's just
kind of there which plays into the story
and that's fine and then this thing gets
pissed off you're like alright now we're
talking now it's paranormal and there's
activity and from there it was really
cool and I really thought it was awesome
it was creepy but it showed a lot so it
wasn't creepy like the first two were
like my brother my sister-in-law me we
went to this movie my sister-in-law and
I are like alright the Paranormal
Activity movies it's on these are
awesome we love them and we both agreed
that the first two were actually scarier
but the third one had the cooler moments
like through these things that happen
you're like that is awesome scary no no
it's not scary cool though like I said
mixed bag and then the end of the movie
happens and I felt like it showed way
too much I keep saying that about this
movie but this is the line I was like
you're officially showing me way too
much I don't like knowing everything
when you explained everything away the
intrigues gone I don't like knowing that
the force is meta chlorines you know
what I mean like you know at the end of
the first paranormal activity the girl
goes downstairs she starts screaming her
ass off and the guy goes down there and
there's no camera down there so you
don't know what's going on it was creepy
as hell right it was freaky you're like
what's happening imagine there's a
camera down there that kind of happens
in this movie I didn't really like the
end it's just that's just me so good
acting again a good premise it has a lot
of cool tricks that aren't in the first
two you know they step it up but it does
show a bit too much at times and it goes
too cool rather
scary they had a lot more jump scares in
this one without a sweet-tooth mask but
still I will say it's a good time no
alcohol required seat it's a great
Halloween movie if you like the first
two you have to watch this one however I
call on one big thing the movie
takes place in 1988 is filming high def
and widescreen on a home camcorder I
call that's officially
nitpicking but I'm just saying so do you
like the paranormal activities what's
your favorite paranormal activity movie
comment below let me know and if you go
on my YouTube page go to playlist you'll
find a playlist that says happy
Halloween there I put a bunch of YouTube
videos and reviews that have to do with
Halloween movies to watch and Joey after
all it is Halloween and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more